هذا البيت المتاكل في المدينه العتيقه في
نابلس كان هدف العمليه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه
قصفه الاحتلال بالصواريخ وفجر الجدران
والهدف قتل المقاومين حسام سليم ومحمد
جنيدي بعد ان رفضاه تسليما نفسيهما
وانفجارات زي صواريخ يعني بيوت قديمه
تفاجانا بعد ثلاث اربع ساعات النشاط
انفجار مش مسترجين نطلع له مستشهدين ناس
بقلب البيت اللي جنبنا
قتل المقاومان بزعم انهما من قاده عرين
الاسود ونفذا هجمات ضد جنود ومستوطنين
وكان مع رفاقهما يخططان للمزيد
اما خارج ازقه البلده القديمه فاستخدم
الاحتلال الرصاص الحي
استهدف مقاومين ولم يكتفي بذلك
بل اطلق النار مباشره على مدنيين فقتله
مسنين ومنع الطواقم الطبيه من الوصول الى
الجرحى تحاول الحكومه الاسرائيليه كما
يبدو تصدير ازمتها الداخليه عبر الخوض
بالدم الفلسطيني والدفع باتجاه تصعيد قد
تنفلت اموره هذه ناحيه والناحيه الثانيه
ان الاعتبار الامني عند اسرائيل اهم من اي
اتفاقيات او تفاهمات حتى لو كانت
بوساطه دوليه
وفي خضم جنازه شارك فيها الالاف وتقدمها
مئات المقاومين اكدت عناصر مجموعات عرين
الاسود وكتيبه بلاطه انهم ماضون على درب
الشهداء في المقاومه
هكذا يصف الفلسطينيون ما حدث فالاحتلال لم
يقتل مقاومين فقط بل استهدف مدنيين بينهم
مسنون عمليه تاتي براي كثيرين ضمن محاوله
الحكومه الاسرائيليه تصديم ازمتها
الداخليه حتى وان سرع ذلك من الوصول الى
لحظه الانفجار الجزيره نابلس